bonjour et bienvenue sur lcp public
sénat c'est l'heure de parlement hebdo
l'émission qui refait le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec michaël szames évocateur bonjour
michael le renseignement est à la une
cette semaine les députés ont adopté de
nouvelles mesures de surveillance
certaines données téléphoniques ou
internet pourront être intercepté le
projet de loi porté par manuel valls
fait l'objet de critiques à droite comme
à gauche les associations estiment que
le texte porte atteinte à certaines
libertés
l'assemblée nationale a voté en première
lecture le projet de loi santé il
instaure notamment la généralisation du
tiers payant de front de gauche l'ump du
déni ont rejeté le texte également
combattu par les médecins et puis on
parlera d'un homme en première ligne
depuis quelques mois avec la loi qui
fait polémique et qui porte son nom mais
qui est donc emmanuel macron le ministre
de l'économie séduit autant qu'ils
divisent on en parlera dans cette
émission
et pour commenter toute cette actualité
nous accueillons aurélie filippetti
bonjour bonjour vous êtes députée de
moselle
ancien ministre de la culture sous le
gouvernement de jean marc ayrault alors
il ya une tradition dans cette émission
on laisse le soin aux parlementaires
notamment aux députés de dresser votre
portrait je vous propose d'écouter
certains de vos collègues et on en
discute juste après c'est quelqu'un qui
a un vrai tempérament je ne partage pas
ses options politiques mais pour autant
j'aime beaucoup à la fois sa conscience
professionnelle si vous voulez
sa sincérité et puis son engagement
culturel qui est réel une femme
d'ambition et de caractère dans l'un
allant avec l'autre elle peut être de
table mais elle est toujours agréable
non seulement à regarder mais aussi très
sympa lorsqu'on discute avec elle or le
débat politique et moi là où j'ai
vraiment fait connaissance et quand elle
avait créé un lit je crois que ça plaît
à dieu la classe ouvrière jours a réduit
en tout cas où il parlait de lissandre
son père puisque son grand-père était un
et un italien qui avait fui le fascisme
en italie et son père était un ouvrier
et la raconter finalement tout ce que
son père ouvrier syndicaliste il avait
transmis comme valeur et moi j'avais
trouvé que c'est un très beau livre
c'est pas une miss qui va laisser une
empreinte dans l'histoire très
importante mais mais j'ai du respect
pour quelqu'un qui qui va au bout de ce
qu'elle pense et qui dit ce qu'elle
pense
on notera femme de caractère avec des
ambitions devoirs d'école de soi j'ai du
caractère oui il en faut je pense en
politique de l'ambition de l'ambition
oui c'est pareil en politique on a
forcément de l'ambition et de bordeaux
mais on n'a pas de l'ambition pour soi
même on a de l'ambition parce qu'on a
envie de changer les choses on a envie
de défendre ses convictions on a envie
de défendre les gens qui vous ont élu
moi je viens de lorraine
je suis élu en lorraine dans la région
où effectivement mon père et mon
grand-père de travailler dans les mines
comme le disait pascal cherki donc pour
moi c'est ça le sens de mon engagement
politique
votre passage au gouvernement vous a
renforcé dans votre caractère dans votre
ambition
oui je crois parce que ça m'a je me suis
prouvé à moi-même d'abord que j'étais
capable de résister aux ordres du
pouvoir
c'est toujours quand même une des
preuves
et puis que je pouvais à la fois voilà
essayer de faire le maximum pour mes
convictions et faire changer les choses
j'ai essayé de le faire et je pense
l'avoir fait notamment sur la
féminisation dans le domaine de la
culture sur le combat pour l'exception
culturelle en europe
voilà donc mais en même temps il y avait
un moment
où je suis arrivé c'est vrai un très
mauvais moment avec une baisse du budget
de 6 % la première année ce qui n'avait
ce qui ne s'était jamais vu dans le
domaine culturel
donc ça a été difficile j'ai assumé sa
courageusement mais pendant deux ans
deux ans et demi et à un moment j'ai
décidé de partir bien entendu je vous
propose aurélie filippetti de dérouler
la semaine en commençant par lundi
puisque manuel valls lundi et à la
tribune pour défendre une grande loi sur
le renseignement à l'assemblée un débat
moins consensuel que prévu sur ce projet
de loi qui vise à encadrer l'activité
des services de renseignement et
légaliser le recours à certaines
pratiques écoutes téléphoniques aux
collectes de données explications très
détaillées de thibault le floch donner
plus de moyens aux services de
renseignement et surtout et légaliser
leur pratique
c'est le but de ce projet de loi un
impératif selon le gouvernement qui
estime que la législation encadrant les
services secrets français n'était pas
suffisante il faut bien se l'avouer nous
étions en retard par rapport à nos
partenaires européens nos partenaires
des autres grandes démocraties
occidentales et notamment américains et
ce retard nous avons la volonté de le
combler quatre ministères pourront
profiter de ces nouvelles techniques de
renseignement l'intérieur la défense la
justice notamment pour procéder à des
écoutes en prison et l'économie le champ
d'intervention justifiant l'action des
services français est très large il
concerne aussi bien la défense des
intérêts économiques et scientifiques
français que la lutte contre le
terrorisme en passant par la prévention
de la criminalité ou la lutte contre la
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive
quels moyens seront utilisés il faut
distinguer deux types de surveillance
celle qui sera à cibler avec par exemple
la pose de mouchards sur les appareils
électroniques le domicile où le véhicule
d'un suspect et la surveillance plus
large qui collectera les données de tous
les internautes grâce à des boîtes
noires de connexion qui seront imposées
aux fournisseurs d'accès grâce à un
algorithme tenu secret ces bois de noir
pourront identifier une adresse ip ayant
un con
fortement suspect sur internet en
commission le député sergio coronado a
fait part de sa crainte de voir ainsi
émerger une surveillance généralisée des
citoyens le texte contient assurément
des moyens d'action aujourd'hui
légalisés ou qui le seront par ce texte
mais aussi des moyens d'exception et
surtout le recours à des techniques qui
ouvre la possibilité à une surveillance
de très grande ampleur pour ne pas dire
une surveillance de masse pourtant le
gouvernement assure qu'il y aura un
garde-fou la cnct air ou commission
nationale de contrôle des techniques de
renseignement composée de parlementaires
et de magistrats la cntr devra donner
son avis sur la pertinence de chaque
surveillance aurélie filippetti vous
étiez présente tout le temps dans
l'hémicycle sur ce texte
renseignements vous avez notamment voté
avec la droite contre un amendement de
christiane taubira pour empêcher les
services de renseignement c'est
contraire en tout cas vous avez votre
vote a été beaucoup commentée vous avez
fait un tweak pour justifier pour cette
question d'autoriser le renseignement
pénitentiaire à agir en prison en tout
cas vous ne regrettez pas c'est comme
ces contraire c'est à dire qu'en fait
c'est la commission des lois et certains
députés socialistes 18 qui ont voté avec
la droite pour faire battre
christiane taubira mais nous moi et ceux
qui vous oppose y ont d'ailleurs à ce
texte
globalement nous soutenions christiane
taubira et nous avons dénoncé l'alliance
de la droite dure avec une partie des
députés socialistes notamment le
rapporteur du texte jean jacques urvoas
pour faire tomber la garde des sceaux
sur un sujet qui pourtant l'a concerné
puisqu'il s'agissait de donner des
pouvoirs de renseignements aux agents de
la pénitentiaire aux hôpitaux pour faire
tomber la garde des sceaux
oui parce que je pense que c'était aussi
un règlement de comptes politique contre
la garde des sceaux de la part d'une
partie pourtant de la majorité qui ne
fait pas partie justement des frondeurs
qui vous vivez ceux qui ont voté contre
l'amendement du gouvernement 40 ils sont
des proches du premier ministre on dit
bah écoutez en tout cas il y avait les
gens une cave et le rapporteur du texte
puis il ya la liste nominative des
députés présents notamment celui qui
était le responsable du groupe
socialiste sur ce texte
le responsable com com com va écouter on
nous reproche en permanence à nous les
prétendus frondeurs de d'être contre le
gouvernement là il y avait un amendement
qui était présenté par la garde des
sceaux mais qui était bien un amendement
du gouvernement qui a été mise en
minorité par une alliance contre nature
entre certains socialistes et la droite
la plus dure eric ciotti par exemple qui
s'en est félicité alors que cela fait
trois ans que ces gens veulent la peau
de christiane taubira qui sont
extrêmement violent avec elle partout
vous le savez dans l'hémicyle d'interdît
jaxx à gauche aussi
certains veulent la peau de christiane
taubira moi je trouve ça inacceptable
que sur un amendement qui concernait
directement les agents du ministère de
la justice sous la responsabilité de la
garde des sceaux
il ya une alliance contre nature entre
la droite toute la droite et notamment
la plus dure avec une palette j'ai fait
aujourd'hui socialiste il a été soutenu
en tout cas par la gauche c'est-à-dire
par 30 députés socialistes alors qu'il y
en a une 18 seulement qui ont voté avec
la droite donc on était quand même
majoritaire par rapport à soutenir la
garde des sceaux et puis les verts et le
front de gauche qui ont voté avec
majoritaire à gauche c'est la première
fois qu'elle est en porte-à-faux par
rapport à la ligne de couleur de peau
mais là le paradoxe est qu elle a
incarné le gouvernement puisque elle
défendu l'amendement du gouvernement
donc on voit bien que certains sont
allés jusqu'à s'opposer au gouvernement
qu'ils prétendent par ailleurs défendre
ça c'est savoir quel gouvernement ils
défendraient il ya quand même un clivage
idéologique sur ces questions on le voit
dans le voir ben oui tout à fait pareil
de mon doigt et d'ailleurs c'est bien le
problème avec ce texte c'est que c'est
un texte on a l'impression que ce texte
finalement il a été conçu pour pouvoir
recueillir le vote de la droite et moi
ça ne me satisfait pas vous savez quand
j'étais député par le passé dans la
précédente législature sous nicolas
sarkozy on s'est opposé un certain
nombre de textes je pense par exemple au
texte sur la protection des sources des
journalistes qu'on avait dénoncé à
l'époque parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
assez protecteur tech sur les archives à
hadopi toutes ces mesures qui finalement
a établi c'est une société de défiance
et moi je souhaite et la gauche défend
la société de confiance donc sur le
texte renseignement il s'agissait pas
d'être naïf angelis de pas ça du tout
mais le texte renseignement le problème
c'est qu'il met en place des outils qui
ne vont pas servir seulement à d
nichée des terroristes c'est bien ça
qu'il faut que les gens comprennent il y
à cette finalité
dans l'article premier du texte pour le
renseignement nouvelle version est l'une
de ces finalités seulement c'est la
lutte contre le terrorisme mais tout le
reste les intérêts économiques du pays
politique étrangère tous à la lutte
contre la criminalité en bande organisée
tout ça doit relever dans allemand du
droit commun ne nécessite pas de mesures
loin c'est évidemment il va trop loin je
crois qu'il va trop loin oui c'est ce
qu'on a défendu en séance avec un
certain nombre de deux parlementaires
parce que d'un côté les outils de
contrôles sont insuffisants la
commission nationale de contrôle 12 et
15 les détails mais qu'il va être loi
qu'il est un peu donc entre la liberté
c'est de contrôler un champ trop large
c'est à dire qu'on va finalement
surveiller les connexions internet de 65
millions de français
et puis les professions comme la vôtre
journalistes les avocats vous même les
parlementaires qui doivent avoir un
statut spécial on ne doit pas pouvoir
écouter comme ça un journaliste ou un
parent ou un sénat doivent être protégés
qu'il sera voté à l'assemblée nationale
est certainement rediscuter on va
s'intéresser à votre parti le parti
socialiste tout le monde est en ordre de
marche
visiblement pour le congrès du mois j'en
vois tout ça et les forces en présence
avec jean baptiste daoulas jean
christophe cambadélis a rassemblé large
depuis l'ailé droite du ps
jusqu aux amis de martine aubry et
qu'importe si tout les oppose sur la
politique économique
moi je suis très content que de cette
motion dont j'anime la direction il y
ait des gens aussi divers que martine
aubry gérard collomb ou bien d'autres
parce que la maladie de la gauche
la maladie du socialisme c'est le
sectarisme des accusations de sectarisme
qui vise l'ailé gauche du parti uni
derrière le député christian paul des
frondeurs qui veulent conquérir le parti
est imposé un changement de ligne
économique au gouvernement
faut le faire évidemment son déchirer le
parti socialiste ça je m'en porte garant
mais il faut aussi avancer en respectant
nos engagements on s'adapte en bien sûr
ou à la conjoncture comme disent les
économistes mais en respectant nos
principes et nos engagements en 2012 une
douce et pas très loin
c'était il ya trois ans et pour éviter
une guerre entre l'équipe cambadélis et
la gauche
une troisième motion a été déposé bordé
par la députée karine berger elle veut
permettre un débat plus large et pas
uniquement sur l'économie c'est vrai que
les deux autres motions on a
l'impression qu'elles sont préfabriqués
elles sont en kit
les négociations ont déjà eu lieu les
militants n'ont pas le droit de donner
leur avis c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe
il va bel et bien y avoir une campagne à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste sur un
certain nombre de sujets sur la lutte
contre le chômage sur la politique
culturelle sur la république sur
l'immigration tout ceci sera tranchée et
s'est pas jouée en grande avance croyez
moi vous aurez des surprises
enfin il faudra compter avec une
quatrième et dernière motion de florence
ogier qui se présente comme une
héritière de stéphane hessel et les
militants eux devront trancher les 21 et
28 mai prochains
voilà pour cet état des lieux des
motions vous précisément aujourd'hui
vous vous citiez ou est-ce que votre nom
a été avancé ne serait ce qu'une seule
fois pour prendre la tête d'une des
motions par exemple celle des ailes
gauche alors notre motion c'est la
motion et christian paul à gauche pour
gagner donc on est un collectif et c'est
par plusieurs la sensibilité de la voûte
les frondeurs la qualifie c'est une
motion qui est résolument à gauche à
gauche pour gagner mais en même temps
qui n'est pas une motion je dirais de
deux frondeurs et d'un régime à ce mot
donc ce n'est pas seulement les
frondeurs on
un champ très large et on est dans une
position surtout de confiance vis-à-vis
des militants je crois que les militants
sont un peu désorienté quand ils voient
que dans la motion à la motion de jean
christophe cambadélis qui rassemble le
premier va les habits de premier
ministre jusqu'à martine aubry mais que
dans cette motion il est écrit des
choses qui sont contradictoires avec ce
que fait le gouvernement en ce moment
même je prends l'exemple du travail le
dimanche
la motion a donc signé par manuel valls
et sans doute tous les ministres dit que
nous sommes défavorable à l'extension du
travail le dimanche mais on est en train
de faire voter ici même au sénat une loi
qui dit qui est en travail le dimanche
dans quel sens ça
comment est ce que les gens peuvent
encore nous prendre au sérieux quand on
écrit des textes qui sont
contradictoires avec ce qu'on est en
train de faire c'est que la voir sur
blanc c'est écrit noir sur blanc n'a pas
de source pour vous je crains que ce
soit une une répétition du discours du
bourget c'est à dire qu'on fait des
grands discours et ensuite on fait le
contraire
et moi je crois que ça ça tue la
politique c'est du monolithisme avoir un
discours très à gauche est une pratique
plutôt centre-droit que vous n'êtes peut
être pas passé inaperçu cette semaine la
déclaration de benoît hamon qui ne croit
pas que françois hollande puis 7 au
second tour 2010 sept nouveaux noms mais
je pense que le problème aujourd'hui
c'est comment créer les conditions d'un
rassemblement de la gauche en 2017
parce que là on nous accuse nous de
faire la division de la gauche
la division du parti socialiste mais
pourquoi est ce que des gens aux
élections départementales n'ont pas eu
envie d'aller voter socialiste
ce n'est pas simplement parce que ça
leur fait plaisir d'aller voter pour un
autre candidat ou d'ailleurs plutôt de
s'abstenir c'est parce qu'ils sont déçus
qu'ils attendent autre chose et donc il
faut qu'en 2010 est notre candidat
puisse rassembler l'enfant l'ensemble
des faits de faire de la vitalité de la
gauche parce qu'ils essaient de faire
visiblement ça ne marche pas puisqu'ils
ont été obligés comme moi quand benoît
hamon dit qu'il ne sera pas où cela il a
pas dit ça benoît hamon d'abord il n'a
pas dit ça il a dit que les conditions
aujourd'hui d'un rassemblement de toute
la gauche qui est la seule manière
d'être au second tour et est
ne sont pas réunies puisque le 49-3
étaient ils ont été obligés d'utiliser
49,3 pour faire passer l'une de leurs
lourds est ce que selon vous une
primaire à gauche serait utile moi je
crois qu'une primaire à gauche serait
utile et même indispensable pour
justement rassembler toutes les familles
de pensée de la gauche
aujourd'hui on le voit tout le front de
gauche ne soutient plus la politique du
gouvernement les écologistes ni son ils
sont aussi défavorable il ya une partie
du ps qui s'interrogent les électeurs
surtout les électeurs de 2012
eh bien ils ne vont pas voter françois
lamy sont allés au québec chez les
autres mais on attendait c'est en 2010
est donc on attend
il en a l on a enchaîné quatre défaites
élections si je vous prenez une primaire
ce qui est bien il n'est pas candidat
naturel
mais pourquoi est ce que le président
vous ne serez pas inclus dans le
processus de la primaire s'il le
souhaite bien sûr en question en tout
cas il faut qu'il y ait une dynamique
qui permettent aux futurs candidats en
2010 est de rassembler toute la gauche
alors en attendant on va dérouler le fil
de la semaine en parlant de mardi parce
qu'après moult tumulte et polémiques le
projet de loi sur la santé a enfin été
adoptée en première lecture à
l'assemblée
ce projet de loi vise à instaurer la
généralisation progressive du tiers
payant front de gauche l'ump udi ont
rejeté le texte
avec chacun sa raison les médecins sont
eux aussi en colère le texte promet des
avancées sociales état des lieux avec
marion lefebvre becker pour 311 contre
l'assemblée nationale a adopté après
deux semaines de débats parfois animés
le projet de loi de modernisation du
système de santé a été adoptée suis
heureuse heureuse que
le débat à l'assemblée nationale est
permis de faire apparaître la cohérence
la logique de cette loi est permis de
montrer que la loi comportait toute une
série de mesures très concrètes pour la
vie quotidienne de nos concitoyens
il ya bien sûr le tiers payant dont on a
beaucoup parlé et puis il ya des mesures
aussi pour mieux organiser notre système
de santé
moi je suis convaincu qu'il y aura un
avant et un après sans surprise les
députés de l'opposition ont voté contre
dénonçant une étatisation du système de
santé
ils se sont fait le porte-voix des
médecins sur le tiers payant généralisé
c'est une erreur fondamentale celle de
la grande erreur du quinquennat de
françois hollande
d'une part on met à mal le système de
santé on déresponsabilise la plupart de
nos concitoyens mais je dirais même que
nous mettons nos médecins sous la
coupole de l'administration c'était une
étatisation du système de santé et on va
mettre à mal le système libéral c'est
une grave erreur
il faudra qu'on la république on prenne
ses responsabilités parmi les
principales mesures la loi autorise les
actions de groupe dans le domaine de la
santé les malades du cancer pourront
bénéficier du droit à l'oubli
le délai de réflexion de sept jours
avant les interruptions volontaires de
grossesse a été supprimé
les salles de shoot seront expérimentés
enfin les députés ont également adopté
une série de mesures renforçant la lutte
antitabac et la lutte contre l'obésité
beaucoup de choses dans ce texte et
notamment cette mesure la dispense
d'avancé de frais chez le médecin de
ville est ce que pour vous c'est une loi
typiquement de gauche c'est une bonne
noir comme quoi on n'est pas dans
l'opposition systématique à ce que fait
le gouvernement
quand y'a des beaunois qui correspondent
à nos idéaux et nos engagements les
soutiens de tout coeur la maison
business de la fa rendu promesse de
france aurait bien sûr sur les
chaussures le tiers-payant donc qui est
une mesure sociale lui permettre pour
que ce ne soit pas les français qui
aujourd'hui ont des difficultés de
pouvoir d'achat qui sont obligés
d'avancer les frais et puis sur beaucoup
d'autres choses
le droit à l'oubli pour les malades qui
ont eu un cancer
malheureusement beaucoup de nos
concitoyens vivent pas dans leur famille
quand vous avez un cancer
ensuite vous pouvez plus faire d'emprunt
immobilier pour acheter une maison et sa
advitam eternam la lune glisse qu'on
réduit les délais vont être réduits
c'est c'est quand même là vraiment
c'était une mesure indispensable
les femmes qui décident d'avoir recours
à l'un
absente grossesse ne se verront plus
imposer un délai absurde de sept jours
entre deux consultations médicales
il y a les mesures sur la santé le
programme pour ses nus c'est vraiment
une noix de coco dont un député qui
faisait du vélo est les médecins de
aussi mais vous savez je crois qu'il ya
une grande de discussions avec les
médecins mais à un moment c'est
l'intérêt général qui doit primer sur
les intérêts particuliers
mais pour penser que le gouvernement s'y
est bien pris pour expliquer sa réforme
qu'il aurait pu faire quand même un peu
preuve d'un peu plus de pédagogie non je
pense que je pense que marisol touraine
a bien fait son travail et elle a mené
cette loi réelle beaucoup de de maestria
c'était une femme engagée et courageuse
et qui connaît parfaitement ses dossiers
il ya eu des mois de discussions sur
cette loi est un moment voilà le vote
est passé
alors mercredi claude bartolone et
gérard larcher ont rendez vous à
l'elysée françois hollande leur avait
demandé des propositions concrètes pour
faire vivre l'esprit duo janvier jour de
la marche de paris contre le terrorisme
alors les présidents des deux chambres
ont rendu un rapport chacun son rapport
paul bouffard l'incitent charles de
gaulle l'autre françois mitterrand leur
engagement républicain est différent et
presque opposés pour gérard larcher il
est essentiel de mieux contrôler les
flux migratoires
la france devrait fixer des quotas
annuels d'entrée sur le territoire cela
en fonction des capacités et des besoins
des entreprises françaises contrôle de
l'immigration au risque que les
communautarismes de disloque la nation
autre point le dialogue franc avec
l'islam
la politique ne doit pas ignorer le fait
religieux pour l'élu ump
l'islam doit s'organiser de manière plus
représentative l'état qui doit être
laïque qui doit ne conserver la loi de
1905 de manière intangible a la
responsabilité de prendre en charge un
certain nombre de relations avec les
cultes dont le socle doit respecter les
valeurs de la république et parmi ces
valeurs partagées je pense à
la question de l'égalité hommes-femmes
claude bartolone lui appuie sur le
développement de la citoyenneté
al'inverse pas question d'immigration ni
de religion ou de laïcité dans son texte
mais plutôt une lutte contre
l'abstention
l'élu de seine-saint-denis souhaite
l'instauration du vote obligatoire pour
toutes les élections
cette démarche pourquoi parce que la
démocratie ça s'entretient
la démocratie ça sirigu et je ne connais
pas meilleure manière d'arroser la
démocratie que de dire voilà je
participe avec la goutte que représente
mon bulletin de vote pour lui permettre
de croître
autre mesure des petits trucs comme il
le dit pour le monde associatif facile à
mettre en oeuvre
création d'un droit à l'engagement
associatif un crédit-temps engagement
pour les salariés effectuant leur
service civique
au final une centaine de propositions
pour deux rapports rester indépendant
car au lendemain du 11 janvier
les deux présidents du parlement
devaient travailler ensemble mais fâché
sur leur vision du bicamérisme ils ne
trouveront jamais de voix commune pas
toujours très fameux travailler ensemble
aurélie filippetti et christophe créneau
kino maupoil pas droite avec nos
partenaires du figaro vous allez
intervenir d'ici avec quelques minutes 4
une ou deux questions et nous aux
questions sur le vote obligatoire c'est
la grande mesure de tirer sort de ces de
ces rapports vous êtes plutôt pour aux
comptes gmail de nous mais je trouve que
c'est une bonne idée parce qu'il faut
que tous nos concitoyens expriment leur
point de vue et certains parfois se sont
tellement finalement loin marginalisé
par la politique
ils vont plus voter mais là où c'est un
moyen finalement de le redire
exprimez-vous mais c'est sûr c'est pas
un droit c'est un peu paradoxal parce
que voter c'est un droit un peu bizarre
d'imposer un droit mais en même temps on
le voit aujourd'hui on a un vrai
problème d'abstention et en particulier
dans des quartiers les plus difficiles
il ya une très désaffection il faut il
ne faut pas que il y ait des quartiers
qu'ils soient totalement exclues de la
vie démocratique je pense que c'est une
bonne mesure et l'autre mesure qui
m'intéresse beaucoup c'est celle qui
consiste à envoyer en stage et tous les
élèves de l'ena et des grandes écoles
trois mois sur le terrain dans soit les
zones rurales déshéritées où les
quartiers sensibles ça je pense que
c'est une excellente mesure pour un
petit peu
ouvrir des horizons aux élèves des
grandes écoles qui souvent viennent des
mêmes milieux et ils ne connaissent pas
suffisamment de la réalité de la france
j'ouvre une autre page aurélie
filippetti quai sur l'ancien ministre de
la culture
quatre semaines de grève à radio france
elle a pris fin enfin cette grève
auriez-vous fait différemment que fleur
pellerin à sa place non moi je ne
commente pas ce que ce que fait mon
successeur simplement ce que je peux
dire c'est que je suis heureuse que la
grève ait pris fin et j'espère que
vraiment les conditions du dialogue
social pour remettre cette maison sur
sur les rails redéfinir un projet
stratégique que tout ça va être fait pas
un gros craquement améliorée oui c'est
un c'est dommage parce que les auditeurs
ont souffert mais comme les salariés de
radio france d'ailleurs pendant
quasiment un mois et que sans doute ça
aurait pu être évité avec avec un
meilleur dialogue social radio france
n'hésitera pas à la réforme c'est cette
aventure nabeul le service public et
réorganisations sont nécessaires mais
enfin c'est quand même un service public
de grande qualité
donc on peut évidemment faire des
modifications dans l'organisme
l'organisation en silo l'encadrement
voilà savez ça c'est évidemment tout à
fait possible envisageable par mois
définir les lignes mais mais il faut
surtout souligner la qualité
exceptionnelle de ce service public
aussi bien france inter que la france
culture moi j'ai un immense affection et
admiration pour france culture notamment
qui est une chaîne radio exceptionnel et
mathieu gallet sa place c'est le csa qui
l'a nommé moi je suis celle qui a fait
je suis celle qui a fait la loi c'est
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel au par
berne et au saut csa c'est donc le ca ca
oui en toute indépendance et il l'a
montré son indépendance en nommant
mathieu gallet c'est le csa qui a fait
ce choix et seul le csa peut
éventuellement révoqué présent dans l
audiovisuel part en ce moment donc le
csa ont effectivement on n'entend pas
beaucoup de ces le csa qui a le pouvoir
en toute indépendance de nommer et
éventuellement de démettre les présents
de dieu je suis très fier de cette loi
parce que ça montre que la gauche
contrairement à ce qui se fait sous
nicolas sarkozy
et bien à une vision vraiment totalement
sacralisé de l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public
justement vous avez peut-être lu que
nicolas sarkozy s'il revenait au pouvoir
reviendrai à nouveau sur cette décision
et ce serait au président de la
république de prendre cette décision
ah bah ça serait une erreur je crois
c'est une héroïne serait une grave
erreur démocratique il ya voilà il ya ma
il ya le président de la république ne
doit pas s'immiscer dans les affaires de
l'audiovisuel public pourquoi parce que
derrière c'est l'information de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
donc il doit y avoir une absolue
neutralité de cette information est donc
des gens qui dirigent l'audiovisuel
public
message bien compris c'est l'heure
d'accueillir notre partenaire du figaro
pour un décryptage de l'actualité
politique
tristan vous allez passer notre invité
sous la loupe du scanner notamment nous
parler d'abord de la réforme du collège
mais tout à fait la réforme du collège
de najat vallaud belkacem suscite
beaucoup de critiques et notamment à
gauche
même jean marc ayrault qui s'inquiètent
pour l'enseignement de l'allemand mais
aussi françois bayrou qui s'inquiètent
pour l'avenir du grec et du latin
ces sondes et des critiques qui sont
justifiées ou pas je partage ces
inquiétudes aussi bien concernant les
langues anciennes puisque je suis comme
françois bayrou on est agrégé de lettres
classiques donc on a eu la chance de
découvrir les charmes du latin et du
grec et
et aussi pour les langues vivantes je
regrette profondément la suppression des
classes bilangues c'est à dire ces
classes où dès la 6e les élèves avaient
deux langues en apprentissage c'était
une manière et notamment moi qui ait
lieu de lorraine pour l'allemand de
rentrée très tôt dans la vie des élèves
il faut revoir ces points 2 c'était
extrêmement positif et il est faux de
dire que ces classes bilangues était
élitiste
je vous le dis dans ma circonscription
et en moselle ce sont des gens qui
savent que ils vont sans doute être
amené à travailler en allemagne avec des
frontaliers dont qui veulent apprendre
la blanc complice avec une courageuse
des collèges je suis content la
suppression des classes bilangues c'est
une erreur à votre avis oui je pense que
j'ai fait une erreur et on nous dit que
par ailleurs on va compenser parce qu'en
fait on apprend on apprendra une
deuxième langue dès la 5e
mais comme le volume horaire global
n'augmentent pas finalement ça va être
une perte sèche pour tous ceux qui
avaient la chance de pouvoir aller dans
les classes bilingues et ce n'était pas
que les les élèves des milieux favorisés
donc ça je le regrette et sur les
langues anciennes je suis vraiment très
très inquiète que le latin et le grec
disparaissent nommément puisque c'est
transformé dans langues et cultures en
langues et cultures de l'antiquité
je pense que le latin grec ça fait
partie vraiment du fondement de la
construction européenne et que si on
veut redonner aux citoyens européens le
goût du projet européen il faut aussi ça
va revenir à l'origine ce qui a fait
notre origine commune
c'est justement la civilisation et la
démocratie athénienne et la civilisation
romaine on a le droit de critiquer najat
vallaud-belkacem
c'est à vous de le dire je sais pas moi
enfin ses protégés à beaucoup je ne sais
pas je ne vois pas quoi vous faites
allusion je sais pas je moi je juge sur
fait donc là en l'occurrence sur cette
réforme il ya le latin le grec qui pour
moi fou partie vraiment de notre
patrimoine commun et aussi ce qui est
très important de dire c'est que pour
les élèves qui sont en difficultés de
maîtrise du français le fait part de vos
critiques
oui je lui ai posé des questions écrites
voilà réponse j'ai eu pour l'instant la
réponse type envoyé à tout le monde mais
je pense que ce débat n'est pas terminé
parce que beaucoup de gens sont attachés
au latin et au crec malheureusement on
le sait en plus le gras qui en avait de
moins en moins dans les établissements
alors que c'est la plus belle langue qui
soit et que c'est aussi un point commun
par exemple regardons du côté de
l'allemagne en allemagne et je vous les
élèves apprennent l on va regarder votre
question traverser l'atlantique
ça vous a pas échappé l'année clinton
est entrée en lice a lancé la campagne
américaine
il ya une véritable illarine magna en
france on voit beaucoup de responsables
politiques qui soutiennent hillary
clinton
c'est votre cas c'est un modèle pour
vous hillary clinton
en tout cas c'est une femme qui a
vraiment de la conviction de la force la
détermination parce que ça fait des
années qu'elle qu'elle attend ça et
qu'elle se prépare à ça c'est aussi la
preuve de la grande maturité de la
démocratie américaine
on voit que ce sont des professionnels
qui qui accumule des expériences avant
de se présenter aux plus hautes
fonctions enfin elle l a eue subi un
échec et donc ça c'est exceptionnel
puisque normalement aux etats unis quand
vous avez un échec dans une primaire
vous êtes éliminés à elle revient et
elle va dieu la sema l'emporter mais en
tout cas il est l'heure et qui le
donnent en france mais je prends on n'a
pas besoin de chercher deux modèles
c'est vraiment en plus un système
complètement différent mais moi je
mettrais favori
je suis pas favorable au système
vraiment présidentielle il pense qu'en
france on devrait plutôt travailler à
des monarchiser notre notre système
institutionnel est ce que vous
connaissez le surnom que le premier
ministre vous donne
j'ai vu ça quelque part mais parker elle
référence au célèbre couple de criminels
bénigne clyde & clyde
vous êtes une faisons politique vous
aussi vu d'autres femmes sais pas si
vous vous souvenez que dans l'histoire
de bonnie and clyde ces bonis en cas qui
finissent criblé de balles pas sûr non
vous l'appréciez où les justifier comme
un ennemi c'est un magnifique film je
vous conseille de revoir le film est
avec avec ce style ouais et warren
beatty qui est absolument magnifique
mais ça se termine très mal donc je suis
sûr que la réalité ne sera pas semblant
ouf merci pour cette loupe du ska droit
parlait d'un autre ministre en vue
depuis quelques mois
emmanuel macron il est monté au front
avec la loi qui porte son nom
actuellement en débat au sénat jeune
ministre qui veut libérer les verrous
les énergies dans son pays
emmanuel macron critiqué à attaquer des
droits sur ces positions qui est donc
monsieur bacon portrait express signé
sandra cerqueira emmanuel macron une
personnalité qui intrigue propulsé
ministre de l'économie à seulement 36
ans cet énarque ancien associé de la
banque rothschild divise la gauche mais
parvient malgré tout à séduire les
français et les politiques aussi au
sénat depuis quinze jours sa loi est
examinée et profondément remanié et
pourtant le ministre de l'économie est
en terrain conquis
il séduit à droite comme à gauche il a
un petit mot pour tout le monde et il a
le sentiment il donne le sentiment
d'avoir le temps il a un grand souci
pédagogique c'est à dire que si vous
présentez une objection il la prend très
au sérieux et ils décortiquent le
problème tant que ça dure assez
longtemps mais c'est vraiment du débat
parlementaire
le jour où sa loi est examiné en
commission spéciale au scénar il fait un
bond spectaculaire dans les sondages
sourire toujours vissé aux lèvres
emmanuel macron se veut disponible à
l'ecoute en toutes circonstances il sait
trouver les petites phrases pour plaire
c'est son style et il le cultive
bon je vais là quand même rentrer dans
le détail parce que je sais que vous
êtes sensible à la fabrique du droit
j'ai aussi beaucoup appris depuis dix
jours et donc mais c'est pas fini
il n'empêche pour ses détracteurs
emmanuel macron est un homme de gauche
dans un costume de droite qui n'a jamais
été élu ria bien réagi à ces critiques
et puis progressivement il a fait
s'est imposée il a discuté il a montré
qu'il était peut-être un personnage plus
complexe qu'il n'en avait l'air dans ces
très jeunes et bien bien rangé alors
dépassé le syndrome premier de la classe
emmanuel macron est l'un des rares
politiques populaires aujourd'hui il
s'installe dans le paysage en à peine
sept mois
une ascension politique qui a de quoi
faire des envieux
qu'est ce que symbolise pour vous
emmanuel macron qu'elle est c'est l'un
des symboles de ce gouvernement
nouveau gouvernement valls donc c'est
une ligne de gauche décomplexée on va
dire qu'on ya eu la droite décomplexée
maintenant il ya la gauche décomplexée
donc pour ma part quand on dit que un
projet pour les jeunes français ça doit
être que tous les fronts tous les jeunes
français aient envie de devenir
millionnaire je crois pas moi je préfère
que les jeunes français ils aient envie
de découvrir au maire ait eu depuis ce
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure que je
préfère de la gauche qui est fidèle à
son histoire et cette fois son électorat
parce que sinon on perd des élections
mais elle les profils est sur
l'électorat aujourd'hui se rappeler qui
vous a fait roi et le premier ministre
qui ne sont pas élus c'est que forcément
ils n'ont pas de coeur de rappel et ils
sont nommés choisis par le président de
la république par le premier ministre
ils n'ont pas été élus donc ils n'ont
pas non plus d'indépendance
l'indépendance et de la liberté que
confère une élection au suffrage
universel et c'est pour ça que moi je
suis très soucieuse de ce que disent nos
électeurs sur le terrain parce que même
si évidemment les militants ils n'ont
pas envie qu'on se déchire
mais quand même les électeurs disent
qu'il ya un problème ils se sentent déçu
floués à quelque chose qui ne va pas et
ce n'est pas avec super une question
personnelle mais ce n'est pas avec la
loi qu'on appelle la loi macron on va
rassurer nos électeurs et en même temps
la france doit se réformer alors il ya
eu des propos très durs cette semaine de
wolfgang schauble
le ministre allemand qui espère que les
réforme s'appliqueront par la forte en
france qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette leçon faite par par le ministre
harb le à la france vous savez le bon le
côté l'autoritarisme allemand ça va on
n'a pas besoin donc relever ou bleu est
un des ministres les plus conservateurs
qui soit en allemagne il faut bien il
faut bien le voir donc le satanique
sherkel encore plus quand guy la merkel
oui absolument
donc voilà la france est un pays
démocratique et heureusement c'est la
france qui gère et défini les lignes de
sa politique en matière budgétaire et
économique
et c'est bien là le problème d'ailleurs
faire ça pour vous il a été abaissée
inacceptable c'est inacceptable c'est
antidémocratique
donc on a on doit vraiment mettre un
terme à cette vision de l'europe où on
imposerait à des peuples souverains
une vision qui est une vision uniquement
c'est uniquement la vision de la droite
allemande qui défend les intérêts d'une
toute petite partie de la population
allemande pas de l'ensemble des
allemands contraire même puisque c'est
une grande partie des populations
allemandes qui est dans la difficulté
aujourd'hui donc le problème c'est que
on n'a pas réussi jusqu'à présent à
taper du poing sur la table et à dire
que ben écoute et voilà on a la france
d'un pays qui est leader dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme à l'échelle
internationale
oui qui balaye devant sa porte et puis
surtout qu'il respecte la démocratie
souveraine en france comme en grèce
comme ailleurs en europe comme en italie
c'est pas l'allemagne et la droite ce
sont tous ces pas la droite allemande
qui doit imposer sa lune à toute
l'europe
aurélie filippetti ou parler des styles
on va comparer deux autres styles c'est
le plus de lait blanc
deux documentaires deux ministres deux
anciens premiers ministres deux styles
france 3 consacrée cette semaine une
soirée au portrait de jean marc ayrault
et manuel valls bassimon barbarie les a
comparés au regard de cela en images non
pas un mais deux premiers ministres en
vedette sur france 3 lundi soir
deux documentaires sur deux locataires
de matignon manuel valls le matador pour
commencer le torero le picador ou encore
le coup ue
l'auteur franz olivier giesberg n'est
pas avare en qualificatif guerrier et
nous livre un portrait haut en couleur
du chef du gouvernement
un colérique un cas sans un adepte du
parler vrai autant d'atouts pour manuel
valls qui lui permettent d'entrer dans
le cercle très fermé des présidentiables
comme il scénarise beaucoup de force il
fait peur et puis les gens se disent
faut il fait dire je serai présent la
république donc vous êtes avec moi ou
alors vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir je dis pas que c'est ces mots un
chat mais il a parlé de cette manière là
mais il ya cette espèce de petite brume
qui perd ou tulle était de trop quand
même pas sa cheikh bass mais avant
manuel valls il y avait jean marc
ayrault
mon père ce héros réalisé par sa fille
élise revient sur ses deux années à
matignon jusqu'à sa démission
une décision déchirante dixit françois
hollande un premier ministre victime de
sa loyauté
c'est ce qui ressort de ce film entre
son camping car et son retour à
l'assemblée nationale jean marc ayrault
casse malgré lui son image consensuelle
pour distribuer quelques piques
ministres qui ont été ministres et qui à
peine sorti disque tout était mauvais
pas trop sérieux une soirée premier
ministrable de france 3 un peu décevante
en terme d'audience seulement 7% des
téléspectateurs s'y sont intéressés
quand vous voyez ces deux portraits
réuni filippetti vous vous les
reconnaissez vous qui l'avez tous vécu
de l'intérieur
je pense que mon dans le cas du portrait
par eddy 0 c'est évidemment totalement
assumée d'ailleurs une relation avec son
père au parlement effective c'est ça qui
est d'ailleurs intéressant dans ce film
mais dit des choses importantes mais je
crois qu'il faut un petit peu sortir de
ce cette focalisation sur le culte de la
personnalité en politique et que voilà
on parle de deux hommes
mais finalement dans aucun de ces deux
films on parle réellement de la
politique qui est menée sur des
portraits ce sont des portraits oui mais
du coup ça ça semble concentré toute
l'attention uniquement sur la
personnalité comme si c'était uniquement
une question de personnalité mais moi je
crois pas je crois que derrière lui
complète il ya des idées il ya la mise
en oeuvre de ses idées comme on essaye
de les mettre en oeuvre
si on y arrive ou pas et la réalité des
faits pas aussi voilà alors après manuel
valls est premier ministre depuis ado
vous le voyez comment aujourd'hui ce
qu'il a changé je crois qu'il a n'a pas
vraiment changé non je pense que il
continue à défendre un certain
des idées de tourner autour de ces
thèmes à lui qui sont le républicanisme
la nation voilà après la politique
économique les définit vous le voyez
encore mais je vois à l'assemblée comme
tout ne vous parlez plus très bon ça
arrive qu'on échange sur des sujets
politiques à l'assemblée nationale vous
n'avez aucun regret d'être parti
du coup maintenant j'ai pas de regret
quand je suis seul et je crois que
l'inde est une des grandes valeurs
en politique comme dans la vie c'est la
liberté et donc le fait d'avoir recouvré
sa liberté et de faire des choses qui me
semble la fois en cohérentes avec ce que
je pense et transparente vis-à-vis de
mes électeurs
c'était pour moi la plus précieuse
vraiment des votre prochain défi pour
terminer cette émission en quelques mots
il avait commencé comme ça d'ailleurs on
va continuer et on va continuer à
essayer de faire de porter nos idées il
ya le congrès du parti socialiste qui
arrive dévoile à la fin du mois de mai
on a un mois pour essayer de montrer et
d'expliquer à nos militants qu'on n'est
pas dans la division mais quand est ce
qu'on est dans la construction et dans
surtout la reconstruction d'un idéal et
d'une majorité à gauche liberté
retrouvée
merci aurélie filippetti dans a été
l'invité de par le monde dont on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine on se
retrouve dans deux semaines oui vacances
et par le moteur à les autres
temps